so I got to ask you about the dark turn
of of that spirituality or maybe you
will place this elsewhere but who was
Adolfo castanzo El padrino this is a guy
that comes up in a period I think is
he's he's at the that initial period of
cartels this is before my time and I've
I've talked to some of the people that
were there for some of that I mean he
kills a lot of people he was exposed and
learned uh through his family ties about
some of the afro-caribbean
spiritualities that are now also
exploding as far as influences across
the world uh Latin America and and in
the US when I talk about that I mean
Santeria
basically some old spiritual practices
Coming Out of Africa that uh
utilize things like in gangas which are
basically spiritual vessels that have to
be loaded with human remains in some
cases
he he was basically a spiritual
practitioner that certain cartel groups
would hire for them to curse the other
side to imbue them with invisibility to
be able to transport their drugs or
protection spells and stuff like that it
was very successful at it apparently or
at least that is the experience of the
people paying for some of these
practices
as his spells and his work kept getting
bigger and bigger and more and more and
complicated the
ingredients he needed for these in
gangas or these spells these cauldrons
that he would fill with
certain elements grew in complexity
till finally he said he needed the brain
of a highly educated American of some
sort
which led to his eventual downfall he
was basically responsible for abducting
and murdering a young American who was a
university uh college student I think
Jinky believed
the so this guy's murdering people to
create what magical potions uh vessels
yeah vessels I think yeah I think I
think he truly believed that he was uh
capable of doing what he was doing I
guess and there's a culture that's
spiritually inclined that kind of
was on the same wavelength as him yeah
it jived I mean some of these spiritual
practices again there's there's a
ritualistic cannibalism done by some of
these cartel groups out there was he
involved in in cannibalism as well he
wasn't involved in cannibalism that I
know of but uh most of the things that
he was kind of known for was basically
requesting human body parts for some of
the spell Works he was doing and then
going to such a level where he needed a
specific brain head of somebody that was
educated and American so that kind of
again led to his uh eventual downfalls
his Ranch was rated they found the body
parts inside of these collards that he
was preparing
that's an interesting example of
somebody there's a cartel head somewhere
in central Mexico as well
uh El masloko was his nickname
and he basically forced the citizenship
around him to turn him into a saint
so he actually made a statue of himself
he was very big into uh Christianity
specifically kind of like the uh
crusader
you know mentality and all that kind of
imbued himself and some of the people
that were around him uh with that
and there's still altars to his death to
him after he died he died two times one
time the government declared him that he
was killing a shootout and turns out he
wasn't dead
so that was his first miracle you know
and then when he was really dead uh some
of his people and his loyal followers
were like gunpoint kind of still forced
to go and you know get flowers and
venerate this these Effigies and statues
of of him as a saint
it's a powerful weapon spirituality in
Mexico is a powerful weapon and
you know the Church Catholic Church in
Mexico was a pretty bad track record but
as far as them control as far as that
being used to control populace and stuff
like that
um and I think uh it's just another
aspect that is being exploited in Mexico
in some communities as far as the
spirituality and the desperate need for
people to believe in something
and how that leads for some people to go
into some horrible predatory behavior
around it